fin de la jornada electoral en España
con una participación del
63,9% en las municipales un descenso de
1,5 puntos por debajo de los comicios de
2019 los titulares la fuerte caída del
partido socialista obrero español del
presidente del gobierno Pedro Sánchez y
la derecha que del partido popular que
obtuvo el 31,5% de los votos un 3% más
que el psoe un cambio de tendencia con
respecto a los anteriores comicios se
hace con al menos cuatro regiones
previamente de izquierdas entre ellas la
comunidad valenciana y con las grandes
ciudades de España excepto Barcelona vox
el partido de ultraderecha normaliza su
presencia en la política Española y
consigue el 7% de los votos en las
municipales Un aumento de votos
concejales y posibilidades de gobierno
de coalición tanto en alcaldías como en
regiones ese primer gobierno en Castilla
y león formado en 2022 con vox dejará de
ser la excepción en Madrid la presidenta
Isabel Díaz Ayuso renueva su mayoría
absoluta así como el alcalde también del
partido popular aquí el partido de
derecha aquí en Madrid me refiero a
posto fuerte por captar el voto latino
que supone el 8%, una táctica similar a
la de los republicanos en Estados Unidos
los sondeos no discriminan por
racionalidad pero el voto
latinoamericano en Europa suele variar
dependiendo del estatus socioeconómico
donde los más pudientes tienden a votar
a la derecha a seis meses de las
elecciones generales las jornadas de
reflexión que normalmente se dan antes
del sufragio tendrán que empezar este
lunes para la izquierda en España y
también está por ver qué papel jugará en
las elecciones de diciembre la nueva
formación de izquierdas de la
vicepresidenta y ministra de trabajo
Yolanda Díaz la formación sumar una
política que ha sido la mejor valorada
del país